makers are scrambling for a way to end
the controversial family separation
policy senators from both parties are
expected to meet today
to come up with a plan to reunite
families along the southern border
president Trump huddled behind closed
doors with House Republicans last night
but did not formally endorse a
legislative fix at O'Keefe his on
Capitol Hill at good morning good
morning John during that meeting last
night as you said the president showed
up told them figure it out but didn't
give him any specifics and there's
growing concern among Republicans that
the administration's decision to
continue separating families could cost
Republican seats in the midterm
elections President Trump went into his
meeting with House Republicans
optimistic telling them he would support
either bill they're set to vote on this
week that would overhaul the nation's
immigration laws and keep families
together who enter the country illegally
it was a reversal from earlier Tuesday
when the president said he wasn't
budging on his administration's zero
tolerance policy when you prosecute the
parents for coming in illegally which
should happen you have to take the
children away images of children being
separated from their parents and held in
cages at federal facilities are causing
headaches for House Republicans ahead of
November's elections he really wants to
make sure we can reunify families and
the bill that we worked on with the
president does just that Senate
Republicans are also vowing to quickly
find a solution we're gonna fix the
problem the president says we need to
act hmm the Democrats say we need to act
and we say we need to act so when that
happens yeah
but Democrats are increasingly
frustrated with the president this was a
policy invented implemented and executed
by President Donald Trump as tensions
escalated Washington a group of
protesters confronted homeland security
secretary Kirsten Nielsen as she ate
dinner at a Mexican restaurant
[Applause]
meanwhile a group of 13 GOP senators has
written to the Justice Department asking
them to pause the separation of
immigrant families what Congress works
out a solution as for that bipartisan
meeting happening here on Capitol Hill
today it's being hosted by Maine
Republican senator Susan Collins we're
told to expect an equal number of
Democrats and Republicans here's the
thing she hosted similar meetings
earlier this year on this same exact
topic and the talks went nowhere we'll
see if this time is any different Gail
thank you and it's so hard to figure out
what secretary Nielsen was thinking is
she just giving a middle finger to the
situation or she just tone-deaf you
would think of all nights maybe you
might have Chinese that night you look
at that and it just doesn't make any
sense
difficult and I think she walked out I
ended up having to walk out of the
restaurant I understand why